he was known to be violent and dangerous
and had told psychiatrists he hears
voices that tell him to kill people walk
downstairs
this is Zephaniah McLeod being arrested
after carrying out that threat
he stabbed Jacob Billington to death and
left Jacob's best friend Michael
Callahan with serious and Lasting
injuries their mothers blame prison
probation and mental health services for
failing to protect them after a report
found their attacker was known to be a
risk I think nothing prepared me for the
sheer scale of failings in our report
um the sheer length of time this man was
known to different authorities and
exhibited dangerous Behavior right the
way through
I find that really quite shocking and it
makes me worry about the safety of this
system for other people I just don't
think that public protection is high on
the agenda at all and you know they talk
about missed opportunities their
failings aren't they that's what they
are the night of the attack McLeod went
into Birmingham city center stabbing
people at random he had a history of
violence and a diagnosis of paranoid
schizophrenia but have been released
from prison months earlier with no
monitoring at all
failure of professionals over many years
to fully recognize the threat he posed
meant that night he was free out here on
the streets armed with a knife
there were four times the authorities
could have intervened but didn't
there are recommendations in this report
it does identify missed opportunities
the job we have now is to make sure that
they are taken forward
but these mothers fear the streets are
no safer now than the night their sons
were attacked Becky Johnson Sky News
Birmingham